the dying Embers of the eruption in
grindvik but the state of emergency here
is far from over tremors are still being
felt and the new fure that runs through
the eastern part of town has widened
even though molten lava can barely be
seen on the surface the town's residents
are still unable to return home gear
Anderson and his partner fled as soon as
they heard the sirens go off on Sunday
night the second time in two months but
I know that I mean some people are
having literally breakdowns because of
this they have since been staying at his
parents' home in the capital they know
they may never be able to return back to
grindvik so many people have already
said that they don't want to return back
to the town then for me it's very
difficult to move there you know because
the community itself is so damaged
living in an area of high seismic
activity will always carry its risks but
the Damage Done by this last eruption
has left many here wondering where
exactly is the safest place to live in
this part of the
country after November's eruption many
were hopeful that normality would return
that hope ended on Sunday when lava
flowed into the town itself they thought
they could go back home so maybe some
people only have a few months left and
and now they need to make big decisions
about their future and where where they
want to live recovery could take years
while the magma pressure May decrease
and shift further out there is little
guarantee that more Fishers won't
suddenly appear changing the landscape
and the communities themselves Sonia
Gago aljazera north of grindvik
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer